hi in this video we'll talk about
prostaglandins now what comes in your
mind when you hear the term
prostaglandin you're right
you're thinking about prostate gland
right some kind of secretion which is
coming from the prostate gland and
you're right prostaglandin was earlier
thought to be as an hormone which was
secreted from the prostate gland and
itself prostaglandin was first isolated
from the prostate gland secretion and
hence it is named as prostaglandin one
Swedish scientist who Vaughn Euler got
Nobel Prize in 1970s for discovery of
prostaglandins
now the prostaglandins though it was
discovered from the prostate gland now
it is known that prostaglandin is
literally present in all kind of tissues
like bone tissue nerve cells muscle
cells and even the reproductive tissues
like testes prostaglandin is actually
derived from a fatty acid known as
arachidonic acid which is a 20 carbon
fatty acid now let's look at the bio
synthesis of prostaglandins in a bit
more details first we should ask that at
a cellular level
where are the prostaglandins produced
and where the prostaglandins stored now
let me tell you prostaglandins are very
unstable compounds and their half-life
is around 30 seconds so they are
produced perform their work and they are
degraded now the prostaglandins has very
high turnover rate now question is in a
cellular format where does the
prostaglandin is produced or the
biosynthesis of prostaglandin is taking
place prostaglandins synthesis takes
place from the membrane phospholipids
now in the membrane phospholipids if it
is cleaved by phospholipase a2 it would
release the precursor for
prostaglandin synthesis which is
arachidonic acid
now from the diatonic acid in sequential
enzymatic steps prostaglandins would be
produced so this is the crucial step
whenever it is required to be
synthesized phospholipase a2 releases
arachidonic acid from the membrane
phospholipids and thereby possible ends
in this can take place
now the key enzyme in prostaglandin
synthesis pathway is process planning H
synthesis process joining h synthase has
two kind of activities one is
cyclooxygenase activity about which we
would learn shortly and peroxidase
activity so the first step of
prostaglandin production is production
of PGG 2 so ironic acid with the help of
the cyclogenesis activity of the
prostaglandin h synthesis incorporates
two oxygen molecules in the she doing
acid backbone and that's the first step
after that PGG 2 with the help of
peroxidase activity of prostaglandin h
synthase gets converted to process
planning now PGG 2 is reduced to the
corresponding alcohol which is P gh 2
and this is done by peroxidase activity
of prostaglandin h-scene tha's so
prostaglandin each sentence is a key
molecule in the biosynthesis pathway of
prostaglandin now this process is a bit
more detailed and bit more complicated
so from prostaglandin h2 with several
enzymes there could be several variety
of prostaglandin synthesis could be
synthesized
for example PGI synthetase give rise to
first prostaglandin in i 2 whereas PGD
synthase give rise to prostaglandin in
d2 and says from boxing synthase give
rise to it from box and a 2 and all
these prostaglandin has different
functions which we would be discussing
soon now we should since we have learned
about the prostaglandin biosynthesis we
should also understand that how
prostaglandin production is regulated at
a molecular and cellular level
now we remember that prostaglandin the
key raw material for prostaglandin
production is an ironic acid which is
derived from the cell membrane now and
it is triggered by a enzyme which is
phospholipase a2 not forcefully by
modulating phospholipase a2 activity the
prostaglandins production can be
regulated right it turns out epinephrine
Dramamine angiotensin ii braddock I mean
vasopressin all positively regulate
phospholipase a2 and thus leads to
production of prostaglandin whereas
steroids kind of inhibit phosphor I
poster blending a tube activity and
thereby the phospholipase a2 activity
and thereby prevent production of
prostaglandins now we also remember
there is another important enzyme in the
prostaglandin synthesis pathway which is
prostaglandin 8 synthase
its activity is triggered by
catecholamines whereas it is inhibited
by compounds like methyl salicylate and
many other similar compounds like
aspirin etc as far as the mechanism of
action is concerned prostaglandins are
found to be working in a g-protein
coupled receptor signaling pathway and
often prostaglandins stimulation leads
to increase in cyclic GMP and protein
kinase a activation followed by several
nuclear changes in terms of gene
expression
several prostaglandins has several
effects on different levels for example
prostaglandin I two leads to vascular
dilation whereas from boxin which is
secreted or which is prevent length will
be present in the trauma sites or the
platelets they induce vasoconstriction
so these two prostaglandins has
different and opposing functions now
prostaglandin I to R which is commonly
known as process light
cycling prevents splited aggregation
whereas thromboxane promotes platelet
aggregation so we can see several
prostaglandin type could have different
and opposing functions and which are
both important in terms of physiology
pgf to on other hand stimulates uterine
muscle contraction and due to its
property like this it is sometimes used
to terminate pregnancy
now PG e and PG f has opposing role in
terms of bronchoconstriction and
bronchodilation PG NF lead to bronchial
smooth muscle contraction
whereas PG e leads to dilation of the
bronchioles pge2 and PG d to increase
the capillary permeability enabling
neutrophil and other immune cells to be
extracted from the particular blood
capillary to the nearby tissue and it is
it has also implication in terms of
inflammation so pge2 and PG d to are
inflammatory are involved in
inflammatory responses now overall all
the prostaglandins prevent or decrease
the gastric secretions and increase
intestinal mobility so these are overall
functions of prostaglandins so this
video summarize the prostaglandins
structure where it was discovered its
function how it works and how the
production of the prostaglandin could be
regulated by our endocrine system so
this was a short overview and
introductory video about prostaglandins
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give it a thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you and do let me know in the
comments section that how you like my
videos and give me some suggestions